So just the nomenclature that
we're going to use here, and
this is taken directly
from the rosetal paper.
We have a couple things.
First of all, there's the actual state,
and they use L for
location, but L is not,
maybe not just be the position.
It might also be the scale,
rotation, etc.
And then they've got an observation
that's called F, and
you know why it's called F?
Because what we were actually
tracking were faces.
But just think of it as the observation,
we're actually talking about
them as being Zs previously.
So the goal is to predict
the target location
based upon our last belief about where
it was and our current new measurements,
and in fact, what we need to be able
to evaluate is this probability of
the location given my last
belief plus my new measurement.
Now, we've done this before, right?
We've said that this equation was
made up of two components, and
we'll just copy them back up here.
The two components are the,
we'll do the purple one first,
that's just our dynamics model.
That says, if I know where
thing was at time T minus one,
what's my belief about where
it might be at time T?
Now in their work here, they used, the
fancy word for it is Brownian motion.
For those of you remember,
that's little particles just vibrating
around doing whatever they want.
Another way of thinking about it is,
they don't have a velocity model.
They basically say, if something is
here In the next frame it's going to be
somewhere around here and
maybe rotated a little bit, and
it doesn't remember
anything about velocity.
So, it's just based upon position.
But the new part that's kind of cool
here is this observation model.
This observation model
is the probability
of the observation given the,
the state, given the location.
And what they're going to do there is
they're going to use that eigenbasis
approximation.
So what that means is, I'm going to say,
if I can reconstruct this patch
well from my basis set,
that's going to be a high probability.
And if I can't reconstruct it well,
that's going to be a low probability.
That's fundamentally the observation
model that they're going to use.